des écoutes françois rebsamen sa
réaction c'est est il ya quelques
minutes et on fera réagir évidemment
stéphanie modde juste après françois
rebsamen donc en ballottage favorable à
dijon ce soir je n'ai pas de dîner
métier loin s'en faut avec les
écologistes on a dirigé en sort de la
ville pendant 20 ans mais ils ont voulu
faire des listes séparées
ils sont partis dans leur coin voilà bon
on se retrouvera peut-être après le
deuxième tour
mais là il n'ya pas question de négocier
y a pas de négociation je suis le maire
sortant je fais près de 40 %
voilà les dijonnais ont renouvelé leur
confiance assez largement donc
donc voilà il n'y a pas de raison
françois rebsamen le maire sortant de
dijon en ballotage donc favorable ce
soir c'est